we are in the channel 8 phone bank to
talk about the medicare health
enrollment time period which is open
right now goes until december and if you
have any questions now is the time to
call these phone lines start to light up
as the evening progresses but when we
first get started it's a really good
time if you have any questions about
your medicare plan or what plan would be
best for you there is the phone number
rick
702-650-1101
with alignment health plan if you come
on in here rick and tell us
about this enrollment period so the
enrollment period is comes up every year
between october 15th and december 7th so
this is that time of year where they
would look at their plans decide they
need to make any changes kind of analyze
where they're at see if anything's
changed for them throughout the year and
rick one of the things you guys talk
about a lot is the medicare advantage
plan yeah the medicare advantage plan is
really kind of nice because it bundles
everything all in one for them so it'll
take and put their part a their part b
the prescription drug plan and then they
add many other benefits like
transportation over-the-counter benefit
grocery benefit so they're just loaded
with all kinds of benefits yeah there
are lots of choices to be made and
that's why it's good to talk with
someone about all the possibilities
right that's right who's eligible for
medicare so anybody who is got that red
white and blue card they're usually 65
and older but not always if they have a
disability and they were under 65 they
would also be eligible so basically it's
based on that red white and blue card
all right rick thank you so much i think
we're going to talk to you a little bit
later as well appreciate your help here
today appreciate these fines folks being
here and already some phone calls coming
through if you have a question now is
the time to call in before these lines
get too busy 702-650-1101
back to you rocky